[音楽]
今すごい緊張してるんですけど今日は
夢っていう言葉をキーワードにして少しで
も皆さんの心に届くようなお話ができるか
と思い今この感じ書かせていただいてい
ますよろしくお願いしますまず
夢っていう言葉を辞書で調べてみると
将来実現させたい希望
理想現実から
離れた空想や楽しい考えこんな意味が出て
きますさてこれらを踏まえ突然ですが皆
さんに質問です今現在
叶えたい夢はありますが
これから実現させたいと思っている理想や
心を躍るような希望は今皆さんの心の中に
あるでしょうか
こんなことを言っておきながらなんですが
私は夢が叶う叶わないということよりも
大切なことがあると思っていますもちろん
このように越したことはありません
本日お伝えしたいのは目を持つことの意味
はそれを達成することそれ自体にあるので
はなくそこに向かうプロセスの充実にある
のではないかということです
だから
夢を持とううまくいくか分からないけど
やってみようそんな私の主張が今日この場
にいる誰かの心を動かす新たな挑戦を
生み出すきっかけとなればいいなと思い
ます
私自身やりたいと思ったことには
挑戦せずにはいられず様々なチャレンジを
してきました特にスポーツに関して今まで
たくさんの夢を抱き挑戦を続けてきました
中でも今日は私が人生の半分以上を共に
過ごしてきているブラックフットボールと
いう競技についてでも経験をお話ししたい
と思います
ちなみにブラックフットボールという競技
はアメリカのボールに由来するスポーツと
なっています
アメリカンドットゴールド行われる
タックルの代わりに
居心地につけているスラックと呼ばれる
着物用のものを取ります
興味の
競技の
イメージが明けづらい方もいらっしゃると
思いますが例えば
野球とソフトボールサッカーとフットサル
みたいな感じであまり特定競技と親戚の
競技なんだなという
認識をしていただけたらいいなと思います
私がこの競技に出会ったのは小学校1年生
の時でしたとにかく体を動かすことが
大好きだったので何かスポーツを始めたい
と考えていた矢先に紹介を受け入院する
ことに決めました
2011年に幼稚舎のミュージシャンに
入学した仲間で結成されたチームで女子は
私1人全9人で特別アニメは日本一でし
た6年生最後の大会の決勝戦で試合終了
間際ファースト13秒で逆転勝利を果たし
ました
日本一になったと同時に私が初めて夢を
叶えた瞬間でし
た中学園入学後は新たな夢を叶えるために
オラクルートボールからは一旦離れ
バスケットボール部に所属しました
チームではキャプテンを務め新人戦では身
の得優勝7年ぶりの大会出場を出すことが
できまし
たところが10月3年生最後の大会では
不甲斐ない試合で終わることになり
夢だった都大会出場には必ず引退すること
になりました
しかし引退直後に現地所属チームから声が
かかり再びブラックフットボールに復興し
ました
2020年2年2020年の夏に
デンマークでブラックフットボールの世界
選手権があるということを聞きました
ブラックフットボールの日本代表選手に
なるこの時私は新たな夢を持ちました
国内最年少でトライアウトに挑戦し一次
選考を通過最終選考に向け夢を叶えるべく
挑戦すると思っていた時に訪れたのが
かつてない世界的な混乱を起こした新型
コロナウイルスでし
た国内国外問わずどんどんすべての
イベントが中止となり目指していた
トランクでの世界選手権も延期となりまし
た
夢目標を見失ったまますぐ毎日でしたが
それでもいつか来るであろうその大会の
ために着実に練習を重ねていました
結局2022年2020年に開催される
はずだった世界選手権は日本の影響を経て
2021年12月にイスラエルで開催さ
れることが決定しまし
た約1年半に及ぶ長い人口期間を経て私は
年間の日本代表に選出され世界選手権への
出場が決まりました
この中で一度遠ざかった日の丸教えようと
いう夢は
叶うことができました
ここで少し世界大会でのお話をさせて
ください
人生初めての世界大会世界
チャンピオンと対決や
普段通りのプレーができる
緊張して
悔しい場面もありましたが自分なりに
ベストを尽くして日本の勝利に貢献する
ことができたのではないかと思っています
結果は目標を達成し世界6位入賞
翌年7月に行われるワールドゲームズへの
出場権を獲得することができました
ちなみにワールドゲームズというのは
オリンピックに
採用されていない
競技種目での国際大会のこと
です実は後日談がありワールドゲームズに
は大会初日までに18歳になっていないと
出れないという規定があり私はわずか4日
足りず出場するという夢は叶いませんでし
たしかしこの大会で日本代表の強さを世界
に知らしめ今後のトラックを世界につない
でいくという重要な役割を果たすことが
できたのではないかと思っています
そして今
プラグフットボールは2028年
ロサンゼルスオリンピックの競技の候補と
なっています
自分自身オリンピックに出るという夢を
叶えるため
チームで自分のスキルを磨き日本を代表し
て
活躍し続ける選手を目指しています
こうしてスポーツを通じていくつかの夢を
叶え
叶えたり叶えられなかったりしたことで
分かったことがあります
それは私が夢がある幸せは夢から
夢を叶えたそれ自体ではなくそこまでの
道のりを
夢中で本気になって駆け抜けたその日々の
中にあったということです
勝負に勝ったことによる地震は時間ととも
に色褪せてしまいます
ただあの日あの時あの瞬間をやり切ったと
いう自分に対する自信は一生いらせること
がないと思います
結果が残すことができたできなかったでは
なくまずやってみた
辛抱強く続けてみたそんな自分にこそ
誇らしさが宿っているのではないかと思い
ます
たった一度の人生ですその人生を
引き受けるのはあなた自身自分自身ですだ
からこそ夢を持つやりたいことは
チャレンジする
踏み出すと最後まで諦めない気持ちが今は
実現する
そう信じて自分が納得いくまで挑戦し
続けるそんな学生生活を送ってみるのは
いかがでしょうかご
清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]